sin duda buenas tardes como lo
mencionaba el ministro de ambiente ha
dejado la posibilidad de que el reino
unido pueda responder de una manera
similar si francia efectivamente cumple
con sus amenazas una situación bien bien
compleja ha dicho además que se espera
que este impasse se resuelva por las
vías de la diplomacia pero si no está
esa otra alternativa ha dicho además que
el barco que fue capturado en las
últimas horas por las autoridades
francesas si tiene la licencia fue
otorgada a principios de este año cuando
se hizo efectivo el divorcio con la
unión europea y ha dicho que el gobierno
británico ha garantizado
750 licencias a barcos franceses después
del break city lo que significa un 98
por ciento de las aplicaciones se espera
además que de la cumbre del g20 que se
cumplirá en roma' como nos contaba erika
el presidente francés emmanuel mccrone y
boris johnson el primer ministro
británico puedan encontrarse una manera
informal para conversar al más alto
nivel y ponerle fin
a esta situación
louis ahora hablemos del llamado a la
embajadora francesa hecho por el reino
unido que piensan los pescadores los más
afectados con esta atención entre los
países luisa
será la manera en la que el reino unido-
expresará formalmente su malestar su
molestia por este comportamiento de
francia que considera inaceptable es una
cita en el ministerio de relaciones
exteriores en el foro no fish esta tarde
no se conoce la hora la embajadora aquí
en londres será recibida por la ministra
para europa y lo que espera el reino
unido- es que la delegada francesa pueda
detallar lo que ha considerado
desproporcionadas y decepcionantes
amenazas por parte de francia así que
esa es la situación pero como les
contaba puede darse en las próximas
horas tal vez mañana una reunión al más
alto nivel entre el premier británico y
el presidente francés para tratar de
encontrar una solución que convenga a
los dos lados del canal de la mancha los
pescadores entretanto han expresado su
malestar por esta situación técnica y
los que lo que piden es que los dejen
volver a pescar para que puedan volver a
cumplir su trabajo sobre todo por todas
las dificultades que ha tenido el sector
por la pandemia del cobi 19